hello viewers i am ivy the android
i'd like to share today's dinosaur
forecast
a dinosaur outbreak will soon occur
residents in the affected area have been
evacuated and a team of exo fighters has
been
dispatched a vortex warning has been
issued
please remain indoors
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i make a sense of this situation
even if you're inviting the chief
breakfast for two years all i wanted was
to be ibs's top five ibs latest dinosaur
forecasts and xoc technology
were able to keep human casualties to
zero
[Music]
development is proceeding under the
guidance of the next jedi leviathan
meanwhile is continues to equip
candidates to become new exo fighters
humanity's greatest hope
[Music]
[Music]
another exo fighter recruit right
welcome to ibs
state of play returns with more
announcements and updates for your
favorite games
we just saw the debut of xo primal a
brand new ip from capcom it hits ps4 and
ps5 next year
next up let's get some eye popping
updates for some fan favorites launching
soon
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
sony
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
later today visit playstation store to
download a new demo for stranger of
paradise final fantasy origin
now let's jump into the world of force
spoken with some all-new gameplay
it is quite beautiful
yeah and uh everything here wants to
kill you kind of way
you know i'm a world changer
that's why i'm so dangerous
nothing could get in my way
[Music]
i'm a top of the world let's finish this
[Music]
that was a new look at the sprawling ps5
adventure for spoken from luminous
productions
let's check out some 6v6 action in
gundam evolution a fast-paced
multiplayer shooter coming to ps4 and
ps5 later this year
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
kaiju brawler gigabash comes to ps4 and
ps5 later this year
next a fan favorite fighting game makes
a beautiful and bizarre return
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
it's
[Music]
[Music]
our next two games will take you beyond
life and death
[Music]
oh my god
i tell her
[Music]
right
ah
[Music]
so
[Applause]
so
[Music]
trapped
in an endless cycle
fighting
dying
returning
always the same
yet always changing
i'm not alone
not anymore
now i stand
before the endless tower
i climb
as sisyphus did
pushing the boulder upward
no matter how high i climb
the challenge
begins
again
but i fight on
through the infinite
seeking answers
[Music]
seeking ascension
my release is within this tower
and i will find it
[Music]
house mark is bringing campaign co-op
and a mysterious new survival mode to
returnal ascension a free update hitting
this march
it's almost time to sign off but before
we do let's get a first look at two
brand new games coming from square enix
is this really what you want
and you are certain that what we are
doing
is best for the people of the kingdom
yes
i suppose it would in a sense
true
yes
it made me wonder
am i still that same person
the era of myths gives way to an era of
great turmoil the continent was ravaged
by the devastating war between the
empire and the alliance
however
one nation remained unaffected by the
chaos
the kingdom of alatane
ward of the august
looked destined to have its soil stained
with the blood of battle
we've finally been called up we're up
against the empire's main army
we are to eradicate every last imperial
who comes ashore keep focused come on
everyone
and now you will die
do you really have such a yearning for
war
i can't comprehend it
[Music]
[Music]
so then
what shall we do now
we're going to retake it
this is our chance while they're all
assembled
we should send our best and crush them
that's right
all the more reason to avoid bloodshed
[Music]
it also likely means that you're in
danger
i suppose it is the only way for us to
survive
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if the will to fight still lingers
within you
then accept my offer
and join me
[Music]
so
valkyrie
here's my words
ragnarok tears
precious
lies on the brink of annihilation
become my tool of intervention
and save this world
[Music]
your efforts to remain undetected are
lacking
reveal yourself
who are you
that's all for today we'll see you soon
with another state of play
[Music]
[Music]
playstation
you